- Le ciel s'était rapproché
jusqu'à recouvrir partiellemente
Saint-Pierre. Au centre de la
place, le cercueil de bois de
Joseph Ratzinger a été déposé,
nourris des fidèles
qui s'étaient déplacés pour
assister aux funérailles du pape
émérite. Présidée par le pape
François, la cérémonie s'est
ouverte dans le recueillement,
par la
(récitation en italien)
Dans son homélie, François
est parti des dernières paroles,
entre tes mains, je remets
mon esprit." Au fil des brèves
le pape a dépeint Benoît XVI
comme reflet du Christ, mais
il a exprimé un dernier souhait.
(récitation en italien)
"Benoît, fidèle ami de l'Époux,
que ta joie soit parfaite
en entendant Sa voix,
et pour toujours."ueueueueueueu0
fidèles massés dans le froid
pour accompagner cette prière.
Dans la foule, le père Romain
sobre, à l'image du pape
Benoît XVI.
père ROMAIN TOLLET
- Je
qui est rempli d'une grande
simplicité, d'undededede
charité. Et c'est quelqu'un
qui ne parle pas beaucoup,trtrtd
dans ses propos.
- Après une dernière bénédiction
du pape François, ououououououos
applaudissements soutenus
que le cercueil de Benoît XVI
a quitté le parvis de la place
entouré de proches qui l'ontacc.
C'est loin des caméras que les.
Le cercueil du pape Benoît XVI
a été entouré de zinc, comme le
veut la tradition, puis déposé
avant d'être inhumé danse e e es
de Saint-Pierre. Aux côtés
pour l'éternité.
Benoît Henri est ressorti ému
- C'est toujours émouvant
ququququque c'est un au revoir à
quelqu'un qui nous est cher. Et
on est tous là pour lui dire
au revoir. Eorororororcément,
ça fait prendre de la hauteul'É.
(chant en allemand)
fait comme lui le voyage
pounununununun ultime voyage
au pape Ratzinger étaient comme
lui originaires UnUnUnUnUnUnUnU,
et c'était un pasteur pour t
Quelqu'un qui nous mène,
qui nous montre le
direct et le chemin saint.
- "Merci, pape Benoît",
banderoles, mais comme beaucoup
des dededededededeuillés, Marie
reconnaît avoir mal connu Benoît
XVI. Pour elle, Jea a a a a a a.
- En fait, Jean-Paul II, ça a
été toute mon enfance. C'estmami
beaucoup de souvenirs de lui.
un peu plus à la fonction
qu'à l'homme qu'on rendait
hommage aujourd'hui.
Radio-Canada, au Vatican.